did you know that most of the time spent
by data scientists goes into wrangling
data more specifically in feature
engineering which is transforming raw
data into high quality input signals for
ml models but this process is often
inefficient and brittle
well i'm priyanka and in this video we
will identify the key challenges with
feature engineering how vertex feature
store helps solve them and see a quick
demo
now what are the key challenges with ml
features the first is that they are hard
to share and reuse across your different
steps of the ml workflow and across
projects which results in duplicate
efforts
second is that it is hard to serve in
production reliably with lower latency
and the third is that there is an
inadvertent skew in feature values
between training and serving usually
which causes your model quality to
degrade over time
that is exactly where vertex feature
store comes in it's a fully managed and
unified solution to share discover and
serve machine learning features at scale
across different teams within your
organization and it also helps reduce
the time to build and deploy your aiml
applications by making it easy to manage
and organize your ml features in one
place it makes the features reusable
easy to serve and avoids skew
now let's see how to set it up
in the console in vertex ai we see the
feature tab to get started let's click
on this documentation and explore using
feature store section
now the first thing you need is a
feature store
at the time of this recording feature
store is in preview so just know that
depending on when you're watching this
there might be more options and updates
that you would see
you cannot create a feature store in the
console so let's use this sample
notebook to
learn how to create it using the sdk
this sample uses a movie recommendations
data set and the task is to train a
model to predict if a user is going to
watch a movie and serve this model
online
we will learn to import our features
into feature store serve online
prediction requests using the imported
features and then access imported
features in offline jobs such as
training jobs
to set up we installed some additional
packages
set up our project and authenticate our
google cloud account
step one is to create data set for
output we are creating bigquery data set
to host the output data
input the name of the data set and the
table we want to store the output later
then we are defining constants and
feature store related imports
here's how the vertex feature store
actually works it organizes the data
with the three hierarchical concepts
feature store which is the place to
store your features
entity type under feature store
describes an object to be modeled real
or virtual and feature itself under
entity type describes an attribute of
that entity type now in our movies
prediction example we will create a
feature store called movie prediction
this store has two entity types users
and movies the user's entity type has
age gender and like genre features
the movie to entity type has the genre
and average rating features
the first thing we do is to create the
feature store
the method to create a feature store
returns a long-running operation that
starts an asynchronous job this may take
about three minutes or so and once the
feature store is created we can see it
in the console
and we can create our entities in this
store i'm creating two entities here
user and movies we can also create
features within these entities
here i've created age gender and light
genres under user and
title genres and average rating under
our movies
if we want we can search through and
filter on these features
now we need to import feature values
before we can use them for online
offline serving
let's head back into our notebook to see
how to import features in bulk using the
python sdk
we defined the data source the bigquery
table or cloud storage bucket and the
destination feature store entity and the
features to be imported
you do this for both users and the
movies entity
now for a latency sensitive service such
as online model prediction we would need
to serve our feature values online for
example for a movie service we might
want to quickly show movies that the
current user would most likely watch by
using online predictions
you can read one entity per request or
even read multiple entities per request
now if you need feature values for high
throughput typically for training a
model or batch prediction then serving
feature values in batch is a better idea
than serving online
consider this example if the task is to
prepare a training data set to train a
model which predicts if a given user
will watch a given movie then to achieve
this we need two sets of inputs features
that we have already imported and labels
which is the ground tooth data recorded
that user x has watched movie y
it also includes the time stamp which
indicates when the ground truth was
actually observed as labels and feature
values are collected over time those
feature values change the feature store
can perform a point in time lookup so
that you can fetch the feature values at
a particular time it's literally the
data version of going back to a previous
version of your source code in github
imagine freezing the state of the
feature values at two different time
stamps
and that was a quick summary of vertex
feature store just know that at the time
of this recording the feature store is
in preview so chances are there are more
options and features available when
you're watching this video to explore
more up-to-date information check out
the documentation that i've linked below
any questions let me know in the
comments or on twitter at pee vergaria